hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
agents of mayhem volition Saints Row
spin-off sharing many characters and
storylines has arrived and these
definitely a game worth considering if
you are on the fence about adding agents
of mayhem to your collection then let me
outline eight ways
agents of mayhem is worth your time
let's start off with the saints row
references in terms of the art style the
familiar purple glow on the hood and the
adult language and comedy elements it's
easy to see how Saints Row housing
practice agents of mayhem what you may
not know is that the story directly
follows on from one of the final ending
cinematic in Saints Row gat out of hell
you didn't play that central title
basically Johnny and Kinzie and dragged
to hell and ultimately make a Satan
their [ __ ] AC true story one of the
five endings allowed God to remake the
universe with everyone taking on
different roles in this new world many
of the Saints and now the Law & Order
including lieutenant johnny gat gat is a
playable character in agents of mayhem -
and although he's only a pre-order bonus
at present it has been strongly hinted
that we will all get access to him soon
enough
agents of mayhem moves away from many of
the mechanics in the States role series
and focuses on being a class-based
shooter or a multi hero shooter if you
prefer but what the heck does that even
mean put bluntly each character has a
defined set of skills which gives them
specific roles to fill in each mission
you've probably seen this in overwatch
where quickly changing a character can
change the battlefield exposing
weaknesses in the opposition or creating
a path to victory agents of mayhem has
this functionality at its core with over
a dozen agents with stereotypical
strengths and skills speaking of
stereotypes each class takes on a
character you've seen a hundred times
before
for example Hollywood is the poster boy
90 movie star hardtack of rich south of
a month with a naval theme running
through and fortune is an ultra fast
member of this guy pirate themed guild
here
infiltrate security system in an
incident but each have different loadout
possibilities and supers of mayhem
attacks for example Hollywood's mayhem
prompt allows him to trace a mission as
if it was an action movie set with
random explosions going off everywhere
and his bullet damage multiplayer if
John wick in any of Arnold
Schwarzenegger characters from the 1980s
had a lovechild it would be Hollywood
although there are elements of it agents
of mayhem doesn't have a typical loadout
of weaponry it instead opts for a team
build each mission allows three
characters to be selected which can be
switched to you on the fly depending on
the mission of course this forces
players to pick the perfect team for the
job if it looks likely that you'll need
to hack and do techy things we mortals
don't understand
then take fortunes there you are pretty
let's take out a couple friends there if
you're expecting a huge amount of
enemies then take a long hard tack for
its up close and personal writing
abilities including a teleporting sphere
to bring your enemies closer to your
vicinity
his mayhem ability transforms his
shotgun into a mine launcher to
completely wreck the legion grunts other
characters will bring more aspects to
each mission such as Rama and her
long-range bow or what about bringing
along Bonnie are you who is a hit man
with a silenced pistol for a most
healthy approach your team is your load
up look at me again and I will remove
your eyes
the story of agents of mayhem pits the
multi nation agency for hunting evil
masterminds or mayhem for short we've
rescuing the world from the grasp of dr.
Babylon and the supervillain
organization Legion or the League of
evil gentlemen intent on obliterating
nations to give them their full title
okay so acronyms aside the story isn't
going to blow you away with complexity
but the cutscenes have a second purpose
as your allies grow new characters are
unlock and the narrative around the
agents of mayhem strikes again with each
new recruit given a backstory and
introductory level to help you
understand that personalities and their
motivation this extra layer of story
really helps you understand the
characters you play as I stored their
medical technology but there was just
too little of it
I had a nation to here each could see
styled in a way to resemble Saturday
morning programming we all watched
growing up some of which has back to the
1980s
we've references to the a team Knight
Rider and GI Joe so as all DS will find
some solace and nostalgia there you're
used to every sandbox game offering a
truly open world with verticality and a
breadth of activities well here's one
area agents of mayhem has attempted to
change things up a little using
procedural generation not all levels
will use this but those that do will
randomly create the landscape to keep
you on your toes and unable to
mindlessly run through a mission without
paying much attention many games
struggle with replayability but agents
of mayhem may have found a perfect blend
of fixed asset and unplanned events the
level of adult comedy and nuance mature
themes from a full-on central title
returning agents of mayhem but those
elements have been toned down quite a
bit
basically there's less vulgarity so
don't expect to find the penetrator in
your inventory but hey you never know
you are with a good soldier if you like
swearing and prepare yourself for an ear
bashing as agents of mayhem is filled
with profanity especially a few certain
characters agents of mayhem will not
offer online multiplayer it will not
include co-op online or on the couch
this is 100% a single-player outing
which can be seen as a
and ashamed to sob to have the entire
development team focused on a
single-player campaign is a blessing in
this day and age but I personally would
love to play this in co-op mode with a
friend by my side crushing Legion and
building towards the same goal but
that's not what we are offered here so I
need to get that thought out of my head
saying that I wouldn't be surprised if
that functionality was added in a future
update
finally Wendy fast travel such as going
back to the ark your time will not be
wasted as the lot of screens will
educate you and makes you an all-around
better person
the Japanese mum manga is the cutest
animal on the planet and if you disagree
with me you can go for yourself so there
you go there's 8 things to love about
agents of paper
we didn't even get time to talk about
the vehicles you'll be using all the RPG
elements integral to progression so
there's so much more depth and
activities to uncover if you choose to
get your hands on this one what do you
think the agents of mayhem I would love
to know your thoughts I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time bargain are
tingling
next time on agents of mayhem